DOA cat who I love just sampled was it
Walk On By Walk On By yeah yeah yeah is
that so cool you're like listening to
the songs like come right back around
you know was amazing I didn't know that
it had been recorded by her and uh my
granddaughter called wait they don't
have to they have to ask permission for
that right no
really that's a whole separate episode
okay they sample it and it's it's theirs
oh my gosh but and and my granddaughter
called me yeah as Grammy yeah do do you
know you're on a record with DOA cat I
said DOA
who she said she she's a rapper and
she's and she was explaining all of this
to me and I said okay and what song are
we talking about she said Walk On By
completely through the entire
song okay well apparently it's a major
hit for her oh no no it's huge paint the
town red yeah yeah and I'm thrilled you
know like I said when I heard it it had
been done I hope walk on byas is good
for her as it has been for me yeah
wonderful I think what's cool about it
too is like PE I'm sorry you can clap
you were
clapping
um I think what's interesting too is you
I grew up on that song I love a lot of
Bert backra obviously a partner of yours
that you worked with a lot but um I just
think it's cool because it introduce
people like a whole different generation
to songs that they might not have known
absolutely and they're great songs and
finally they're being exposed to yeah
good music yeah amen yes
[Applause]
[Music]
yes thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home